Eckersdorf Feldbach
Prozent der Stadt folgende Fragen der
Stadt so war es meine erste Frage was da
irgendwelche
denn Jahre schätzt dass so ein Produkt
das der Lieblingsfilm
zweite Frage ist warum findest du nicht
auch dass das Wort Selbsthilfegruppe
Michaelskirche ist mein Lieblingsteil
Minister halte sein National Bank
gelassen
ich bin ich ganz Klein war ein
wer einfach sauer weil wir einfach los
machen an die BayernLB weiter alles
durcheinander die 9 alles mit dem was
jeder geht seinen Reihen 30 Elena
Felsenkeller im Keller finden muss man
sich angucken muss man einfach gut
finden
Euro entgangen dass der Verkäufer
Jahren
weiß auch nicht wie du darauf kommst so
Hamann
Selbsthilfegruppe
ist ja ein nicht ganz lieben dank ihnen
waren zur Selbsthilfegruppe selbst
wählte er selbst ist selber
Hilfe neuester und Gruppe in der Gruppe
also einfach ich habe keine Ahnung so
sein weiß auch nicht einen Supermarkt
in Zukunft nicht allein nicht ganz klar
zu sein